so I think it's fair to say that by
design human beings are great
complainers we have a unique skillset
unique capacity to find what's wrong
with the world and hopefully intervene
address it and make it better our
capacity of imagination to imagine to
design to create has allowed us to
rework the world to improve upon it to
augment to upgrade to set ourselves up
as engender gods and goddesses who soar
through the sky with technological
marvels to create cognitive appendages
and prosthetic extensions of mind tools
that we design to design us in return
our capacity to find what needs fixing
is a gift what's not a gift is our
overuse of that capacity the fact that
we're never ever satisfied the fact that
we're never ever satiated right we have
more than we've ever imagined
we are wealthier and more privileged
than any other time in human history and
yet we always look for a reason to
complaining so the question then becomes
how do we address this right how do we
both celebrate our capacity to make
things better but also learn to
appreciate what we've got and what we
have achieved
right so key buzzword these days in the
self-help movement people looking to
address the anxieties and neuroses of
the modern age is how do we learn
or grateful how do we practice gratitude
how do we learn to count our blessings
each one of us is already a miracle if
you can breathe if you can think if you
can love if you can earn you've won the
lottery and you just think of all the
sperm that you had to triumph over to
get to the egg that conceived you for
nine months you were safe merged with
the visionary being known as your mother
finally through the birth canal emerged
into a world of inconceivable wonder and
mystery floating on a rock in the middle
of a universe that is bigger than
grandeur that we can even model with our
greatest mathematics and yet here we are
right
visionary beings aware that we are aware
right with his capacity to generally
possible to imagine to conceive to
create to design to upgrade again I've
said it again and again and yet we
complain and yet we're depressed and yet
we're popping pills to a squash your
anxiety and so again what do we do we
need to practice gratitude we need to
learn to say thank you thank you
amidst the inconceivable cosmic ash of
nothing we are here and we can love and
we can yearn we can dream and we can
have sex and orgasm my friends we have
it all and we we just need to learn
to appreciate the fact so I'll leave you
with that gratitude gratitude from
addict
[Music]